[Música]
actualización de las noticias desde la
economía como jorge hurtado un nuevo
saludo para ustedes jorge y vamos a
revisar los temas de hoy en economía
estamos haciendo el seguimiento esta
mañana al conflicto entre rusia y
ucrania y las implicaciones que esto
trae así es que mientras occidente y
europa ya están barajando algunas
opciones para sancionar económicamente a
rusia de una ante una posible invasión a
ucrania eeuu ya busca nuevos proveedores
de energía este lunes el presidente de
eeuu joe biden se reunirá en la casa
blanca con el emir qatarí también bin
hamad al zani con quien hablará sobre
cómo garantizar la estabilidad de los
suministros globales de energía no es el
primer encuentro de alto nivel que se da
la semana pasada la presidenta de la
comisión europea úrsula von der leyen y
el presidente del congreso europeo
charles michel conversaron con el emir
catarí para reforzar la alianza
energética con ese país al que
consideran un socio fiable qatar es el
mayor proveedor mundial de gas natural
licuado y podría ser un jugador clave
para europa si el conflicto de ucrania
interrumpe las entregas de gas ruso al
continente la agenda también incluye
pláticas sobre actividad nucleares con
irán y las relaciones con afganistán
donde el país del golfo representa los
intereses de washington rusia
actualmente representa el 40 por ciento
de las importaciones de gas para europa
y el conflicto despertó de la necesidad
de diversificar sus suministros
energéticos y más temprano también
estábamos hablando de los datos de la
economía de la eurozona así es que el
producto interno bruto de la zona euro y
de la unión europea se expandió un 5,2
por ciento en 2021 así lo confirmó la
oficina europea de estadísticas eurostat
en el cuarto trimestre entre octubre y
diciembre del año pasado las economías
de la eurozona y del bloque comunitario
aumentaron un 0,3 y un 0,4 por ciento
respectivamente la cifra representa la
primera estimación de crecimiento para
la cifra interanual del 5,2 por ciento
tanto en la zona de la moneda común como
en el bloque comunitario aunque esta
cifra dice la agencia es preliminar y
está sujeta a algunas revisiones en 2020
el bloque europeo sufrió una caída
provocada por la pandemia que representa
el 5,9 por ciento de su producto interno
y una noticia que traemos en desarrollo
ya de hace varios días en chile el
gobierno autorizó una flexibilidad de
restricciones para desbloquear un
importante paso comercial así es
tuvieron que modificar inclusive sus
protocolos sanitarios para desbloquear
este paso fronterizo llamado cristo
redentor donde miles de camiones se
encontraban varados desde hace algunas
semanas el paso fue bloqueado este
domingo donde por dos semanas
permanecieron parado unos 3.000
vehículos de carga según confirmó la
federación argentina de entidades
empresarias del autotransporte de carga
argentina y chile- establecer un nuevo
protocolo que exime del test de
antígenos a aquellos conductores que
presenten una prueba pcr realizada 72
horas antes de su llegada a la frontera
aunque a partir del miércoles el pcr
deberá tener máximo de 48 horas
realizado el paso fronterizo cristo
redentor es estratégico para chile y
argentina así como para la región los
camioneros que transportan allí desde
brasil y uruguay llevan sus mercancías
hacia los puertos chilenos para los
envíos a todo el mundo escuchamos un
poco que decían estas personas que
tuvieron que pasar por ahí
dos semanas bueno acá nosotros llegamos
al final 15 días digamos el lunes pasado
no la anterior cuando
habían pasado los últimos 150 también y
se decidió cortar con las razones que un
poco la mayoría conoce que es el cambio
de reglamentación que implementó chile
en el despido a los colegas que me
negros concejala con esta medida a pesar
de toda la pandemia si es bueno
que el país de chile proteja la cuestión
del coi pero también tiene que dar una
flexibilidad más que todo a los
conductores que vivimos encima del
camión dormimos trasnochamos
entonces
ojalá esto haya servido para
congestionar más el paso gijonés para
los televidentes que se conectan a esta
hora con nosotros recuerden los los
indicadores que tenemos de la jornada
bueno los mercados bursátiles amanecen
mixto y vamos a empezar en asia donde el
nikkei de japón cerró en positivo
impulsado por las tecnológicas y luego
de que el primer ministro de ese país
asegurara que no considera la
posibilidad de decretar un nuevo estado
de emergencia por el avance de la
pandemia en europa las acciones
tecnológicas lideraron también el
repunte de las acciones europeas aunque
persiste la preocupación por el aumento
de la inflación y el conflicto en europa
del este pues gracias a ustedes por las
noticias jorge vayas a descansar y nos
vemos mañana
[Música]